[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
sleep
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
make
[Music]
okay congratulations
all right
they didn't hear none of that but
what's going on guys this is uh
you know let me go ahead and turn these
off one thing i don't like about
about streamlight um about this is like
they don't they don't let you see like
outsource stuff until it's too late if
that makes sense like
it shows up in stream why it shows up in
obs
as like a black background like if you
have media on it like you can't actually
see it it's probably a setting or
something like that to turn it off but
uh i don't know about it yet but what's
going on
it's the attic show once again returning
where we talk about the past
present future gaming i'm your host uh
addict and uh there i got my co-host
with me
hustle motivate what's going on hustle
oh man not too much not too much uh it's
good to be back
boy i'm tired did a live stream not even
like 20 minutes ago i have fun one of
the topics that we probably won't cover
but we should cover is the rumored xbox
series x and ps5 pro consoles which was
leaked by king's favorite uh tv brand
tcf i feel like we gotta leave that like
how do you
come out there openly and put on a
platform like that it
like i i'm we'll get into that yeah
we'll definitely talk about that we'll
probably talk about that first to be
honest with you and then we got
108 dragon what's going on sir
what up man last time we spoke with uh
pax he's brother and and thanks for
having me hustle my guy over here like i
like i like you too your show is crazy i
appreciate it
thank you shout out to tim last week too
here funny guy oh yeah
man
man what's on one monday
shout out to tim though you got it yeah
so y'all your big name should be green
dog
that boy be promoting boy let's get it
we had uh we we me and 108 we actually
went to pax east that was a a very
interesting uh
event you know what's funny is i will
never forget
we were at that place and you guys got
that food and i will never forget how
equally disgusted everyone was on that
food we ate like i've never seen people
that disgusted with food in my life but
it was hilarious and it was epic
uh so obviously as you guys see we we
got a pretty stacked show for you guys
today uh you know i'm very curious to to
see what we're going to talk about man
we got
playstation playstation anti-consumer
move man i'm sure some of you saw uh the
crazy stuff they're doing with that uh
you know upgrading
for a cheaper package upgrading in
general looks like they might be making
you pay the difference we got xbox
turning down huge games and we got game
pass versus versus kotaku and we are
going to stick like also said the the
mid-gen refreshers we're gonna go ahead
and sneak that in the show too uh so you
know first thing you guys know how it is
we're gonna ask the guests what top you
want to start with want to wait what
topic do you want to start this show
with out of what i just said
we're going to go ahead and start with
the
kutaku versus game pass thing uh how
many of you that i'm assuming both of
you saw the the tweet that was made
with uh kotaku and then uh game pass
clap back at them uh you know i find
that very interesting for those in the
chat that don't know
kutaku posted a article that was pretty
much saying that you know the big
aaa games and game pass is uh kind of
like starting to weld down so people are
you know maybe not necessarily seeing
the value in game pass anymore and
what's funny is game pass actually like
the twitter of game pass like the
official xbox game past twitter tweeted
them and said tell me you don't
play
trip uh indie games without telling me
you don't play indie games there's
something related to that i think they
might have yeah that's exactly what they
said and uh so you know i'm very curious
on that uh we're gonna go ahead and
start with uh 108 dragon our guests like
when you saw that what was the first
things that was going through your mind
first thing i said is about time y'all
stand up for yourself stop letting
everybody whip on you all the time you
just go hey play games
it was good to see
um first of all let you know let's talk
about kotaku's history with this game in
general they don't really talk facts
they'll get out there and make one of
these crazy articles
and then everybody responds and acts
crazy but let's just be real here
they've been doing this
for at least 15 years 10 to 15 years
easily
and you know
i don't even i don't even like going to
the topic but it was good to see
game pass the official
twitter feed
clap at them and say a whole lot because
these dudes is crazy
even even with the whole
i'm cutting off my game pass as soon as
you do that every drm is going to kick
in and all your game is going to stop
working that's what's going to happen
dudes don't that's not reality man and i
just think i think taco need to be
better but they're never gonna change
and the response that they're getting
is the smoke that they want
we feeding right into it you know what
i'm saying it's like it's like they're
professional trollers
that's what i thought about it man but
it's good to see microsoft you know
say something more you know put them on
the spot and to be fair
i don't even think they're like
they're that that good of trolls like
they they they're one of the the people
in the media
that constantly
say they don't want to like encourage
you know any type of console or nonsense
but
that's literally all you see them
write about right like and it feels like
there's a difference between making an
article that you know is going to start
constable
foolishness
then
doing one because you know it's going to
uh you know for instance if you talk uh
you make an article about any type of
like exclusive you know if you make an
article about talking about like you the
lack of aaa exclusives for xbox like you
know that that's probably going to start
some form of console war stuff but if
you're making an article to start the
console war stuff so you can get the
traffic i feel like that's a little bit
different uh how did you feel hustle
like i i know i know you'd be looking on
these twitter streams don't like you
don't
[Laughter]
well i'm gonna tell you this
when i saw it
shout out the friend of the show tony
polanco he thought that it wasn't the
real game pass account doing that first
of all it was second of all i'm here i'm
here for it it's like somebody whoever's
in charge of the wendy's social media
account they got to hold the xbox game
pass and they want all the smoke and
they was going and um shout out to nxl
too and exile kind of you know hit them
up with the one-two punch people was
trolling trying to troll in excel in the
chat and that's how i was leaning on
them boy they was like oh you can make
two somebody in somebody in that thread
was like oh in excel that's real mature
you you can make two memes but what have
you done in the last you know six years
or whatever in the last five years and
it was like six games and two dlc
expansions it's going on people duh i'm
here for it and um you know one of which
you brought it up earlier i don't you
know i don't got an issue on microsoft
being super positive but at the end of
the day man you can't just keep letting
people just smacking around smacking the
face and all that you gotta i mean you
gotta let them know what time it is
sometime and um
i just thought it was utterly hilarious
like coach yeah listen kotaku getting
the attention they want that's why i'm
like they they doing what they do they
know what they're doing just like we
earlier this week i'm not sure if you
two are familiar but there was a young
lady and i'm not gonna mention her name
or anything she had said something in
reference to game pass and being the
minorities like you can't afford it if
you're
a black or a brown person
i heard about that i thought that was
fake i didn't know that
no
that was that was a real thing and it
was it was yesterday it was it was
yesterday as a matter of fact so when i
when i see stuff like that i think
people know what they tweet
and it was just people know what they're
doing kotaku knew what they was doing
kotaku wasn't expecting that response
and i'm gonna be real with you if i'm
cool taco i wouldn't respect that
response either xbox be chilling maybe
come by y'all holding hands skipping
through the field
uh when we when we all play we all went
over where that phrase is and that was
used for you know disabled people and
what have you but a lot of people use
that and that they're pushing that
narrative it's like oh it's about all of
us no well yes and no but
that whole thing to me was was
absolutely hilarious um
alex had did a video known as alex hit
that video on this whole thing i've i
got a good kick out of it this morning
man um kotaku they ain't really
respectful it hasn't been the same since
uh oh shreya left and i know a lot of
people ain't necessarily big on what he
does but i can say that he's like a real
journalist over there like
you can tell he's missed sadly and um
talking for anything i'm gonna keep a
trail with you even when schreier was
over there who really went to kotaku
nobody i'll always be forgetting their
website i'm gonna be real listen they
they are very forgettable they always
they even print bad gaming information
like
who who who who uh spots checks this
reads when they hit before they upload
them because they're they're they're not
a good site they're just not good
and
they're not they're not talking with not
no facts they're just
saying stuff and then people like oh my
god game passes is losing and and and
all this game passes for minorities or
people that's poor because
now that you brought that up hustle
yesterday i went into a couple place uh
playstation spaces on twitter and i
don't get involved with the console but
i always listen to the gamers and one of
them said
game passes for poor people
i said what so i just went in there to
listen and that's where i heard
this this lady young lady say some crazy
stuff so i was just like
yeah if i find that tweet i'm not gonna
mention the person's name but if i do
find that tweet i'm gonna tag you my
response more or less but that whole
thing was hilarious no kotaku man they
i know like if i often talk about like
integrity right like you'll never see me
like oh
oh yeah oh that's for sure like you'll
never see me
hop up on camera and like address
and then yeah i mean like right painting
my face right now like cuz i got i just
got too much
integrity for myself like i would never
play like that i got too much integrity
for myself plus once you put something
out on the internet it's there forever
that's why i be careful about what i'm
talking about be careful what i say when
i don't know what i'm talking about i
don't got problems saying all that um
kotaku in general man i mean like i said
they fell off since ryan left man i mean
you know and when were they ever really
on is no i was getting say that
and you know kotaku they think you know
they're going to come at me with some
i'm built for that baby but i mean
it doesn't even matter
like
like they troublemakers that's what they
do yeah
they they try and they they're really
reaching with a lot of this and i just
think it's um
i think it's i think it's i i do want to
like get some people's thoughts in the
chat as well about this but they hey
listen man i ain't never really seen
because i because y'all been around is
longer than me i never really seen like
a company get like ratio like that i
never really seen that i've seen like
doom gameplay
seeing that for the first time is like
yo like whoever this gentleman or lady
was who wrote that article was like it's
like yo you your credibility took a hit
and you want to it's going to be a long
time before you like repeat that you can
be right about 10 more stories they're
still going to look at you like not yet
and if they were to do this the
playstation you know they're hitting you
with the same smoke right so they doing
the same thing but there's a lot of
but they're also one of those websites
people got to remember
them and um
is it game spot
no no no
yeah game spot
they get paid by people clicking on they
they don't really got a lot of
commercials they get paid by attendance
um so if they say something
controversial
oh let me go read what they wrote
boom
you know what i'm saying so
you know i got into it with uh
gamestop's one of the dudes who reviewed
the game it was gears four
and
he says he gave it like a six
and i was like
do you even play games and he was
falling like no so i'm like
why would you so hard on the game how
could it be a six
i mean i don't care about
people's reviews cause i'm gonna play my
games regardless but i just was like you
do know mad people read this you
obviously know this and you just saying
stuff to get people to you to your uh
to your site because you get paid by
clicks
and he was like we have to do what we
have to do and this was a review
i i personally feel like you know
we got to do a better job not feeding
into this when these people do stuff
like this
we are the reason kutaku is relevant
because
well not me particularly and i don't
know no no we have given them that
attitude uh you're right it says you
know
twitter have given that uh that
that power because uh you know
regardless some people will look at that
title and they won't actually go into
the article there's a lot that do and
but
when you quote tweet it talking nonsense
about that actual tweet guess what
people are doing uh they're oh they're
looking at that and they they click onto
it you know it's just like it is what it
is like you know what's funny is like
when you have like a huge person with a
following
like a couple hundred thousand they'll
quote tweet it and talk negative on it
and i'm just like you literally just
exposed that article to a hundred
thousand potential people yes and you
know even if one percent of them clicked
on that's an extra thousand views that
you gave them that you didn't right you
literally gave them
you right
i told somebody i talked i talked about
that the day in the space
and they was talking about the people
being toxic i said well if you don't
give them a platform they don't have a
voice
and they'll be talking to themselves
don't give them the attention that
they're looking for
it's simple
but you know it is what it is man
twitterverse will never stop it's
undefeated
it's undefeated
it's at the end of the day it is what it
is you know
if kutaku don't do it someone else is
gonna do it
you're always gonna have these platforms
that will do stuff like that because
shock value is so easy to jump on to
and
just because gaming might not get you i
know sports people
you know someone writes some crazy stuff
about their favorite sports person
that's gonna get you car people someone
someone talks about like ford and you're
a big forward person that's gonna get
you like it's not just a gaming thing
it's it's it's oh no it's not my thing
people will do it as much as they can i
don't know why
netflix decided to just turn on randomly
on my tv but that's besides the point
you know
that's because they're listening
i felt the same way you saw me get up
i'm like why is my house door opening
like it was like
[Music]
i was like what the hell but no you know
the the whole thing with salacious
titles i mean
i'm gonna say who but youtube they'll
tell you to do that too so it's just
and i try to stay away from that unless
it's something i'm really covering like
i try not to say like the people uh the
new god not got a wall um the new um
thor movie like if i if i jump out the
window if i did movie trailer reviews
and all that and i said this trailer the
god award thunder love trailer is trash
and i do the mean face and i do it like
i put my through yeah yeah but that's
going that's going to get somebody to
click on that drone you know so yeah so
that's that's that's part of that game i
get it but i don't eh this isn't my
thing i tried
friends and they're and co-creators are
doing the same thing what i do i know a
few i know what i don't like is the fact
that everyone gets under the same
umbrella to a lot of people
when i make a
a youtube video that the title isn't
clickbait it's just interesting i will
admit that there is different levels to
clickbait i make a title that says xbox
got huge news people like why you click
baiting addict like
and the reason people are like that is
because you got people like kotaku
that's going extra 24 7 on click baiting
articles is like here
having an interesting title is
is clickbait but it's not bad clickbait
it's just like look it's
you got to play the game or you don't
play no that's pretty much how they beat
their interest yeah
and it's it's it's very annoying when
people try to
like launch everyone to the same click
baiting title like
don't what i consider true
negative click bait
is having a title that has nothing to do
with the video itself you go in there
and they they have pretty much
bamboozled you just to come in there
just to give them a view sure their
watch time ain't going to be the
greatest but if you're tricking 10 15
000 people to go in there for a minute
minute and a half before they realize
it's not what it's about then clearly
you're gonna you know that that's going
to be beneficial sure it's not going to
be on the watch time but
youtube does more than just one
algorithm they do it on a variety of
things uh what kind of engagement you
have in comment section how much it's
like like they do it multiple different
ways and people need to realize that
that title and that thumbnail are
extremely important to get people into
the video one of the most important
things but espn did it to me one day
the title read
lebron james
talked about jordan disrespectfully all
he said something it's something that
way so i clicked on and said what did
this dude say about you know you get
enough problems i hope you really i
watch this thing for 30 minutes they
didn't even mention the title
they got me
yo they got me i was like you see
this is i said they even talk about
lebron and jordan they talked about a
whole bunch of other stuff and not one
time that they mentioned what lebron
said about mike it was just for the
title espn is guilty too hey before we
go on real quick one away i got a
question for you have you heard of the
phrase
this is a no-fly zone have you heard of
that phrase yes i'm sure you have you
know where it came from right no
oh wait
what okay from a trick trick out detroit
this is the no-fly zone it was on a song
by royce the five night called gangster
nice i'd say i like to say this
you brought up the espn thing
um there's like no fly zone i think they
were talking about the falcons all right
it's clever playing on words you know
them the same as espn monday night
football i know well i'm eric i don't
know if you watch football but i think
you do want to win i know king of them
i'm a big football fan so you know the
whole um i'd rather pick my teeth out
oh man
out in new york he had a he had a
youtube channel like he would do like
the like all the stupid stuff people
would do on the internet he would hold
up a sign and say come on get out get
out of here with that bs one more jay
they actually did yes then they actually
stole that from ed love it yes being
actually stole that from air lover as
well and i was heartbroken behind that
because they didn't pay that man at all
there's a lot to do with espn i know it
had nothing to do with nothing but i
didn't want to i wanted to bring that up
because first of all they always
watching so when you come up with
something you gotta patent it you gotta
make sure you got it on top of your p's
and cues i didn't want to bring i know
they had nothing to do with nothing um
as far as the clickbait titles and
thumbnails and stuff i wanted to expound
upon that
i can i literally i don't know if you
help me out with the views on that but i
literally did and worked kind of hard on
my turtle's revenge thumbnail
and i did it twice and i got that video
got over because i only got 600 and some
odd subs one of them videos almost had a
thousand views and the other one i think
is at 500 but my point is that thumbnail
is eye-catching that thumbnail will
catch you and i try to keep my
thumbnails authentic to actually what
i'm talking about but that's just me
that's just me um so all that stuff
works as you mentioned before all that
stuff from the right i need to get
better my thumbnails man i'm always in
my thumbnails but i'm not going to do no
you know
shredder shredded revenge i played at
the pax and it's not good and this is
why
can't wait to get my review copy
oh lucky y'all i got to pay for it but
oh ooh okay no i'm not gonna go into
this thing
i was about to go into a whole turtles
monologue i'm gonna do that i'm gonna do
that my phone at it go ahead
you guys are ridiculous
i mean when it comes down to it uh i
just i feel like like i said people need
to leave it better on talking uh you
know
let's go on discord and call them
foolish let's not like promote them
and then they get more views like
you are literally putting more money
into their pocket by talking about them
than you put into your pocket by not
talking about them so it's just like why
do we keep doing this but it ain't
really much to go into that you know i
guess we could go a little bit into
uh let me get this super chat by flame
real quick we got a two dollar super
chat from flame the game patch ratio was
delicious xl is a goat yeah xl
entertainment you know go out there and
try wasteland three it's a really good
game i actually reviewed it on this
channel on my channel you can go out and
watch that uh it is co-op game it is a
co-op game so i think uh you know
it's always fun to play something with a
friend but you know obviously we see a
lot of people unsubbing to game pass
here lately
and
the biggest thing you know i want to ask
you guys because we got 108 in here is
do you think that what we're seeing with
people unsubbing is justified or do you
think that it's cloud chasing because i
see a lot of people uh going around that
they think it's just for attention and
i'm curious what you guys think about
that so what do you think won away
let's just be real here
right
game pass is the best deal in game right
sony's making an effort to try to
compete
let's just be real here
dudes don't get they way
i'm getting rid of my xbox i'm i'm every
shirt i bought i'm burning it
listen listen listen they cloud chasing
i don't see nobody i don't see none of
my friends talking about that
i only see people on twitter saying oh
this is what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
unsub now everybody they making spaces
about it
they they want to get them clicks they
want to get them views
they're talking about it the content
creators yeah bad people are un subbing
from game pads where do you get these
numbers from
that didn't come from microsoft
you just you just talking and you cloud
chasing because honestly
who wants half a day library to
disappear
because those games will no longer work
dr ram will kick in we said that before
the show bye
i'm not gonna not have my games because
oh
starfield got delayed
okay suck it up grow up there's a lot of
games getting delayed stalker two got
delayed too
um horizon forbidden west
missed the holiday season too
games get delayed
it's no reason for this uproar but it's
more of i need attention
i need somebody to stroke my ego make me
feel better today somebody should say no
don't leave game pass we're here for you
i'm not doing that you go ahead and do
it and you'll be right back do you think
that
they might have done it a little bit to
get like microsoft's attention
internally
like having microsoft like dm them like
what can we do for you here's a survey
we'd like you to fill out no
hail to them
i do feel like microsoft is very
reactive when it comes to twitter and if
someone big enough was criticizing their
service i do feel like they might want
to have like have a conversation of what
they might truly doing wrong
true and what was the biggest thing they
ever decided to do
and we all should know this in this room
the biggest thing is when they said they
was gonna raise the price
of life
oh man remember that
that's something to respond to
not a couple of dudes talking about i'm
unsubbing i'm sick of this
no not them dudes but when you got
uproar of over a million people talking
about you raising game pass
i mean um um xbox live
to 120
that's something different but they're
not going to respond to this because
it's not it's it's the
it's the meat heads talking
it's not it's not that i'm not getting
rid of game pass and i wasn't on a game
fast hype train in the beginning
because they didn't have what i needed
to be in there which was big titles and
especially with the announcement of
first party titles so you know when i
got to e3 they took care of me in
game pass is the ultimate
i'm still waiting to pay for it
i'm not unsubscribing not unsubscribing
that was that's crazy that's nonsense
even if even let's say even if these
people are not gamers right and they're
apparent
you give your kid a system
and a subscription based like game pass
right
they got hundreds of games that they
would never get in
in four or five years time they got
hundreds and hundreds of titles that you
don't have to come out of your pocket
but ten dollars a month
what parent would unsubscribe from that
and go back to gamestop and buying games
or buying the games from the store
hustle did that even make sense
no not not the way i grew up for damn
sure let me let me tell you that i i'm
gonna be real with you why i love my
physical games and i'm gonna answer the
question in the second edit i love my
physical games and my my titles and i
wanted to always own something now this
game game passes though regardless of
whatever grapes i might have with it
because you don't own it because you
actually don't own it but
it just is what it is um
let me ask you a question
did i unsubscribe from game fast no
did i announce it on twitter no no of
course not and this is from a person who
has physical games and a lot of and
enjoys my physical content um
yeah you had asked whether whether they
was clout chasing the net yeah it's
definitely the latter and not the former
dog first of all
anytime i unsubscribe from whatever i'm
subscribed to guess what i'm not doing
i'm not hopping on the phone and i'm not
tweeting it out i don't like this
service no more
okay
let me button real quick okay
i agree with you guys i do uh for the
most part
uh we are spoking individuals but we
don't live on twitter like
like that's our everyday life thing we
all have like regular jobs like
the people that came out and spoke
they literally criticize for a living
um that's what they're used to they're
used to going on twitter and giving that
opinion now
i do think that gene like the the person
who who started all of this
i don't think he was clout chasing
no not at all if you read his tweet i do
feel like he
was just generally like look
right now i'm not saying that xbox isn't
a value because i do think it's a value
but
i don't have time to play the games
that's that's there and the games that i
want aren't there
i feel like he was genuine
he wanted just to and he even said i'll
be back when the games drop that appeal
to me i feel like that's fair criticism
that's extremely fair criticism but
that's not really a criticism that's
just he that's his opinion but that's
not a criticism
we all know they got a ton of triple a
games in there they got dope uh uh uh uh
indie bangers because check the yummy
jumped in there day one you cannot tell
me everything in game pass you played he
must have played everything in game
faster that he wanted to play what
unless does he review games
see here's the thing if he reviews games
and he's from big websites he's probably
getting the majority of these games free
anyway
so why would he need that service if
he's getting review codes and he's
getting to play the games before the
game even comes out
so i can understand that logic because i
don't think here's the thing
we need to stop acting like and i'm not
saying we as an us i'm saying like
twitter as a whole need to stop acting
like
xbox game pass was tailored just for
your ass because it wasn't
xbox game pass
is
a
a center of multiple genres that come
together to try to appeal to as many
people as possible to keep them people
into that service all the time
hardcore gamers
this is different because all the stuff
that they put in there
besides like the day one indies and
microsoft's day one games we probably
already own that [ __ ]
i'm gonna tell you what it did for me
addict okay
i'm i'm like hustle i like hard copies
the reason i do digital cause i game
share
right that's the key but let me tell you
what game pass did for me
wasn't with it at first once they
announced first party titles the end
date
now you swam me over you bringing cause
i'm i'm the dude to bother collectibles
all this other stuff i don't care i'm
just gonna do it you know what i'm
saying
but what they did for me is i'm playing
stuff that i refuse to buy i'm playing
more indies now and giving them a chance
where if you drop that in the store
with a a great trailer and i'm like i'm
still not paying for that
you understand what i'm saying so it's
more than just i'm a hardcore dude
but
look what they did for me
they would have charged me fifty sixty
dollars for trick or young me
i'd have to wait till black friday
because and i buy everything they want
certain games i'm not gonna be paying
that money for just i spend too much as
it is
so it's like
it gives you a bigger library and it
gives you opportunity to try stuff you
would never purchase
and you know what's funny too 108 uh is
you look at something like trackie only
like
i'm pretty sure playstation's tired of
them going out getting these marketing
deals because they had to show up on
their show they was heavily marketing
that game to a point
and then microsoft popped them all
because that's cute but it's in game
pass day and date because at that point
what
you need a king cut out face so when you
go into your king moment you pop it up
and you talk behind it because how do we
know king isn't going into my moments
okay
why do i have to automatically go in the
king moments
because you know how he gives it up
that was the king
good one i love it keep going it's just
look at the end of the day it's like i
said game pass
i do think they need to do better in
terms of making more games that appeal
to a bigger audience i know they're
lacking a little bit in japanese uh you
know support now they are doing better
uh you know they got stuff like dragon
quest in there they got stuff like this
uh italian chronicle rising game they're
getting the
the big uh game they're making next year
um but i do think you know we need to
see stuff like final fantasy 7 remake
hit that pass we need to see uh you know
even if you can't get that
you need to go out there and be more
aggressive getting those type of games
in there you need you gotta you got a
head you got a fighter market that is
starving
that you could easily put killer
instinct in there and and raise
subscription services because of that
now i will admit first person they're
gonna be fine after the activision's
done you got halo call of duty i don't
think they're gonna have any issues on
that uh you know sports i think they
need to do a little bit better on that
i'm not a sports person but i can
understand 2k 22 is in there yeah
and
and
and i agree on that but i do feel like
you know that's something that people
would like for that like
i do understand where people come from
in terms of certain of these scenarios
uh
but microsoft is doing the is doing a
phenomenal job having as many genres in
there like i only named a couple
literally one or two
i do think that you know the sports
could improve a little bit but you do
have a point there's a lot in there i
don't really play sports uh but i mean
when it comes to no date you gotta look
look at this at home give me a second
they got the ea play
you get your foot you got madden
dropping in there remember
the day and date with uh uh the uh
baseball game
that's you the show yeah that's huge so
yeah maybe dropping 2k in there every
other every other month 2k is the only
basketball game out there yeah you right
that's major
they got hockey covered anything going
ea played remember that's part of game
pass
i think maybe i'm talking about more of
a
you know i i do know people
like the the smaller sports in there too
i i don't necessarily ain't too many of
those guys oh yeah i get that i hope you
may talk about rug rugby 2018
oh man
well at the end of the day i do agree
with you uh i am wrong in terms of
sports they they do a good job in sports
uh keep in mind like i said i don't play
i see what i see on twitter um right i'm
not doing research with these people so
they want more sports and maybe they're
talking like dane dates i mean race is a
sport they got a ton of races i mean i
think they got every john recovered they
even dropped octopath traveler
big game pass that's it's a lot over
there hey
that was big let me get a few of these
super chats before we get like following
i'll get them here
okay cool i thought you didn't have
access yeah you know i see them i just i
don't know if i see the members yo if
there's a member in the chat do a member
chat real quick so i can see if it pops
up on this thing thank you okay let me
um
let me read some of these super chats
real quick we got a five dollar super
chat from drawn tj hey guys i hope
microsoft next year buys ea yeah we're
gonna talk about that we're gonna talk
oh boy you know what you know we might
talk about that next we want to take
flame was at the beginning
yes
i got the next one too uh then we got a
five dollar super drop from
uh
decado
probably butchered that but you know
what it's your fault for making your
name back so uh i'm not a game pass user
in hopes and dreams in the future i am
there for what i play there now game
pass would just have not to have games
for me to cancel i agree um i don't know
anyone that's buying game pass for games
in the future uh for the most part now
what i will say is they do a good job
surprising you throughout the month
where yo what's coming out next month
what's coming out this month
though on a random tuesday in the middle
of the month they'll be like you were
jumping 15 games really
and i think
a lot of people don't really take
advantage of that
and i feel like that's one of those
things that they don't get
they don't get enough credit for because
sure it's been kind of a dry spell when
it comes to the xbox platform and their
exclusivity this year it's hard to
complain when you got stuff to play i'ma
be real with you it's hard to complain
when they're dropping stuff consistently
into game pass that's keeping you
what's what i'm looking for you see the
member chat yeah i see it it isn't there
i appreciate that uh
heated heavy 505. addiction
don't have
bad bad men oh okay that's that okay
okay i know what you're talking about
man you ain't getting me i know what
you're talking about
so that that's what i'm saying like
xbox
game pass
gives enough people some sprinkles man
we'll call it sprinkles they sprinkling
that little stuff over sure you want the
appetizer we in the appetizer stage of
the year i mean we might be in the
appetizer stage for the whole year but
i've never seen anyone
[ __ ] about appetizers likes
it's just like at the end of the day we
do want aaa stuff we want more quality
stuff and i agree on that but it's like
i said last week and the week before
some of these games are going to take
more time and some of these games was
delayed by the pandemic and if you feel
like it's too long of a wait for you
then i understand go ahead
and unsub
do your little public public leaving man
we publicly even mass appeal
i think it's weird but it is what it is
and come back when it appeals to you
but
why there's people out there that's been
saying it for four days
every day they're talking about it it's
just like dude
i get it
what
i'm not rolling i'm not rolling it's
cloud chase i don't want that right back
i'm not doing this
let me get this real quick two dollar
superstar from flame xbox needs to add
triangle strategy just saying great game
and i think there's a good chance it
happens unless uh sony buy square units
continue hustling well no no it's
definitely a club chase dog i mean you
look at
we've seen it we even seen it yesterday
um not to bring up a tragedy but anytime
something get the popping like really
popping and i'm guilty of it too and i
look look i put my hands up of course
you know i might get in get into a
conversation
but i don't ever try to like tweet out
stuff that's like oh we're gonna get
this much trash and this much attention
the stuff that i see a few people
comment on and i'm not gonna say their
name on that like that but
you know
i i see them just commenting on
everything that's popular
every single thing like you can do it
every now and again and make it look
make it look less obvious but when you
do everything like it's like the same
names
i'm like yo come on i'm like yo y'all
got nothing
it ain't nothing to you i look like dude
and let me ask you both a question
how many triple a's honestly released
every year
i would say a handful of them call of
duty as always right a handful so when
these people keep begging for triple a's
what triple a's are you waiting for or
what triple a's you expect because
god awards a triple a we're in 2022
we're about to get a new one so you
gonna you gonna just play god of war the
first one and just go all right
we had halo 5
and we waited all these years
to get a new one i think so hot gears of
war when the next one coming how about
that i didn't get what i'm but look what
i'm saying it's like people keep saying
triple h triple a triple e how many
honestly
do they drop
it's the medium-sized games the double
la games the indie games that carries
the the year out and then you get that
banger the end of the year it's not you
won't get triple a this month triple a
next month triple eight that that that
is not the schedule that is not the
schedule i do feel like that's the case
if you take an individual stance from
one platform to another but i feel like
if you add the whole community
sure it's not i do feel like there is
pretty much a couple triple a's every
month but it's not like mainstream
triplets like you got like dying light
to like uh i would consider that a
triple a wouldn't you dying light a
triple a game i would consider dying
light two a triple a put a one in the
chat dying like two's a triple a two in
the chat of dying like two is not a
triple-a to you guys i'm curious and i
do wanna
i do wanna say this though in regards to
the people unsubscribed from game pace
have you played and beat all the triple
a games all the first microsoft first
party games on the joint because that's
see that's kind of what i want to know
because i still got game pass for um the
obsidian game um
not drawing to death oh my god i'm
blanking on the name but um it's with
pavardi in it the chick and it's the
first person joint um made by obsidian
attic you know it because you put me on
to it i still i still got the rpg yes
it's all out of the world out of the
world how the world is it like i got it
solely for that now as far as gears go
like attic no i love kids so i love gigs
five in particular i bought that day one
so if we really want to talk about you
know i'm unsubscribing from that's
another subscriber from that that's fine
i just want to make sure that when
microsoft tests you unsubscribing when
microsoft drops something they want make
sure you cop that like i did
make sure you cop make sure you cop the
big titles day one like i do the thing
is though hustle
and 108
people it's like i said people need to
stop acting like
game pass
caters to the just them
and i feel like they
i i know we're probably going to get a
foursome most likely at the end of the
year i know i'm not playing that damn
game already i can tell you that right
now
but i'm not mad at them for giving us
that game you know what i'm saying
like it's just like
outer worlds stuff like that they
people don't realize this stuff
that was going down microsoft is lucky
to even be like xbox not microsoft they
would be fine regardless xbox is lucky
to even be around right now
in terms of you know being still with
microsoft and the fact that
sure
i we could we can make an argument that
they took too long to respond to certain
things
but i think we can all admit that look
it's it's funny to to see all microsoft
bought this microsoft bought that when
are we going to get these games
it's criticism of saying that we need
the games now
but when you go out and you spend this
type of money you're eventually going to
get that those games
it's just if you don't want to wait i
get you don't wait uh but you know what
i do want to move on to is we have an
interesting thing that i feel like we
should talk about
it's this playstation anti-consumer
thing did you guys see
what i didn't see that one so apparently
there's people out there that's getting
discounts you know how like you were
getting the discount
and then they were what they were doing
is they were going out there and getting
like the
the um
they're going to like amazon or whatever
and getting like the discount ones
yeah so then they were going on there
and re-upping
uh first it was confirmed uh through
like some uh you know japanese uh
consumers that they were making them pay
the difference
and now i've seen more people tweet
about it saying that that is
going to be the case
uh now what's you know what's crazy i
want to point out
that regardless if this is true or not
let's say we're going to be in an attic
world man like i said the attic world i
can make whatever the hell i want and
then in the attic world
this is true
what's crazy is no one talked about it
yesterday
i didn't see one video really from
big content creators i didn't really see
media write about it too much
like
imagine if microsoft went out there
and they're actually doing this they
actually done this where if you add xbox
live gold you convert it to ultimate and
you could take literally all the the
gold that you had make that ultimate and
you wouldn't have to pay a dime until
that gold
subscription they already did this
exactly what sony's doing
but guess what microsoft didn't do for
one they didn't go out there and say
okay
we we
we we're not letting you do it anymore
we realize that you the consumers are
smart they're going out there getting
like 10 years worth of [ __ ] we're not
letting you do it no more you can have a
couple but you can't add no more
playstation cards to your service you
can't stack anymore they disabled
stacking
microsoft didn't do that they're like oh
we're gonna keep you for five to six
years and you're probably never gonna
leave this service
sure
because you're you're a customer for
five to six years we good with that
sony's like oh
no that's not good well we you're going
to pay
everyone rotate rotate rotate but then
it's like that person in the chat that
person in there that's like but but sony
we we give them the ability to stack i
don't care what we give them the ability
to do turn it off
it's just it's crazy that people didn't
really talk about that you know someone
brought it up momentarily but they're
like people are finessing the system i
don't believe it but they should they
they uh but they should honor that okay
so then we thought it was over we
thought you know
i get it i understand
i don't agree but we're just got to move
on with our life so then sony took those
people that was going out there to the
amazons whatever those cards were and
they're like guess what
we know you thought you finessed us
but we really finessed you
so when we do this update you'll get a
pop-up
that says give me your money you know
that like that card thing that that king
said like you're going to sit there and
we you know why the playstation 5 is so
big
because when stuff like this happens the
top just splits and a card reader pops
up and it says swipe your card to
continue using this playstation the
funny thing
the crazy thing is like i said it's not
the issue on whether or not it should be
done sony has the right to do whatever
they want to do it's the fact that no
one talked about it it's the fact that i
saw very few people make videos about it
and then they sit there and act like
i don't understand if if microsoft did
this where they're like okay you guys
got good deals what we're gonna do
is we're going to sneak around after you
already bought it you already gave us
money and we're gonna hold our hand down
and we'd like give me some more
likes
you can't
it's like there's two lanes to go into a
club you got through the first one man
you got your ticket and they're saying
we need the second ticket before you can
go in the club but i already paid the
first ticket oh that was the one to get
in here to pay for this one to get in
the actual club
it's just it's crazy man it's crazy so
you know what let's start with hustle
hustle
what is your opinion because i saw you
over there i feel like you ain't feeling
my conversations
well i i kind of you know and i got
slammed up for everybody of course
however i do want to give people just uh
because i i would love to know when the
time when all is kicked off because we
had
an unspeakable tragedy which i'm not
going to go into happened yesterday so
if we didn't see people cover it i'm
sure that was the reason why because
that thing that happened yesterday that
made national news attention that's the
only like real reason
right so that's kind of why i figured
why that didn't pick up sting yesterday
um
no but there was one guy i don't know
who he was but i'm assuming he got there
from like a dealer and ran and and a few
of them feel the xbox cats where
everybody was upgrading their service
and it was you know capitalizing on it
because it was a one dollar to upgrade
the premium or to xbox ultimate
one guy and one gentleman i'm not sure
of his name but he got ps plus for 10
years he got to be filling it right now
cause he got paid for that apparently
and like i do kind of i remember seeing
that floating around and hopefully other
people will cover it because i'm more
interested to know hey are they going to
grandfather him and they probably won't
but his playstation grandfather him
meant to be like uh we see what you did
don't worry we're going to hold you down
or was jim going to be like nah
we want some more money get give me give
me all that bread you got in your pocket
give me the leg give me the give it all
here he says give me your pennies give
me your certs you said everything
once they take your bank account you
start walking out and you know you they
done took everything man they took the
house the car
they took the dog the less attractive
wife
towards the door and then sony just gets
right in for the door blocking the exit
and they're like what else do you want
from me you ain't leaving without my
shirt give me my shirt like so it's only
the person they want everything they
don't care they they want it all and you
know
they deserve to be like that because
they're a corporation corporations do
that but there's a difference between
still making money and still being fair
and i feel like sony has done nothing
this entire generation
but be unfair
they have did stuff where it's like the
70 dollar
games which you know i actually am a
little in the middle on that i do feel
like there is to a point where we can't
go years and years and years and years
without expecting some type of raise so
i don't really go too much into the five
the ten dollar raise i i feel like okay
the industry at this point deserves that
because it's just like we we didn't
raise the prices in the 360 generation
or the xbox one generation right did we
expect to go another generation without
a raisin in base games i don't i to me i
don't feel like that but
hit
playstation will sit there and they'll
be like
okay you guys bought the ps5
we gonna need that ps5 tax you want to
use
you want to use this thing here we gonna
need that ps5 tax oh
you want to upgrade from the ps4 version
of spiderman to the ps5 spiderman
we don't need that ps5 tax and then like
oh you want you you want to upgrade from
the regular playstation to the new
playstation plus thing
we don't need that ps5 tax and guess
what
no one has said nothing about the ps5
tax people will sit there and be like
but addict you know uh this thing right
here they they spend money for this
they they should be able to charge for
this
when i brought it up nothing okay i get
that nothing people real quick real
quick i'm gonna cut you off but dude i
feel like it's necessary in this case
pixel bit g2 super chat the ps5 upgrade
issue has been reversed to three hours
ago
okay everything else is reversed
spider-man's reverse people act like it
goes away because they reversed it they
sat there and tried to screw you over
and finally they come back but here's
the thing you guys let something i'm not
saying people in the chat i'm not saying
people in the thing people out there in
this twitter verse this big ass twitter
hole we'll let some of this stuff go and
not other stuff of this go that's why
you got 70 games because no one said
nothing that's why you got ten dollar
upgrade fees because no one said
something like people act like just
because they reversed this doesn't mean
they try to do that in the first place
do we get did we give xbox credit for
reversing the xbox uh gold thing we did
well technically they didn't reverse it
because they never started it
sony had the reverse
that that's the part that blows my mind
we didn't give xbox credit for that we
said you without your damn mind anyway
this is the way it should have went i've
never known better
they were by the way the xbox was by the
way they shouldn't even play it like
that that that that to me was
was wow you're charging that money for
xbox gold but that's come on
for life
see all they technically did
what that is they said look we give you
discounts if you buy it we're no longer
giving you the discounts they didn't
technically raise it they just stopped
giving you the discount but it's just
like you're thinking
but no see what they did is they stopped
offering you the yearly discounts that
you got half off up into that point you
could buy a year of discount and get
that year half off and that's why you
was getting that and uh that's that's
the part that you know
they didn't technically raise it but you
can't offer a service like that for like
two decades and then expect people to be
okay with taking that away that's why
i'm okay with this playstation plus
stuff because playstation plus
i consider this new playstation plus a
game pass competitor sure it's not the
greatest game pass competitor but i
still think it is a game pass competitor
because they
the best service
and the reason game pass does so well is
it because of those first party games
those first party games do well they
raise the nerves but you know what keeps
people in the service it's the tunics
that drop monthly it's the
these random indie games that drop
monthly it's the nba show that dropped
monthly those are the games that keep it
and i feel like playstation has done
that well on the playstation
plus essential
subscript i don't know what they call
them three tiers that's what they do
well and i feel like that they did good
uh and i'm hoping that microsoft sees
that and they're like okay
you know they do have good games in here
they put god of war in there they put
paternal that just came out now recently
ago came out like it was a year ago that
uh ratchet and clank's not in there yet
but you know they might end up throwing
that in there uh they they put the ghost
tsushima uh you know game of the year
whatever the hell it's called they put
all that in there and
someone coming out the street that's
just buying a playstation didn't play
any of those games
that's going to be a good service to
them they're going to sub to that now i
don't know how it's going to start
working when you see the outer worlds 2
hellblade 2 all these other games that
microsoft is eventually going to get i
don't know maybe i'll be have grey in my
beard by then which i already got some
great in my beard so that's beside the
point i don't know how long that's going
to be
but they are eventually going to come
out we'll have to see how playstation
handles when that happens because if
those games start dropping and they're
doing really well metacritic-wise
review-wise stuff maybe not necessarily
sales because why would you buy the game
if you can get it in that subscription
i'm sure they'll sell well on the pc but
if those subscriptions start scott
soaring through the air and people start
seeing xbox is this place where you
could go for it and be very economical
thing where you can go play all the
games that you want to play buy some of
the games that you want to play and you
get all this value on xbox you get to
play the out awards you get to play
whatever they do with halo here going
out and i could see that being a
scenario where people are like what i'll
buy a playstation when they start
dropping stuff i want not playing
anything over there on playstations it's
not exclusive but i got this stuff
called game pass over here on xbox that
i can play fable outer world hellblade
2.
avowed you you got um uh elder scrolls
six probably wolfenstein three starfield
indiana jones and then call of duty
overwatch like when people start seeing
these games constantly dropping in game
pass you're gonna start seeing people
have to choose between the platform keep
in mind we're still at the beginning of
the generation for the most part the
vast majority of consumers that are
casual people have not invested into a
console yet when they start seeing their
key components like the the call of
duty's the the overwatch twos these huge
juggernaut things that's on a game pass
and you can literally walk into a game
shop at walmart pick up an xbox series s
or x leave there with call of duty brand
new that year it's gonna start hitting
different
we're gonna have to have see how
sony handles that microsoft right now
it's easy to kick someone while they
down because they've had to delay games
it's easy to do that but when these
games start coming out and if they're
good you're going to see sony react
differently and i'm sorry i completely
went to array well technically you
really on point and you had a thousand
points there because this was crazy
once that happens sony cannot respond
microsoft has more studios
they don't make triple h fast enough
this is why my whole point in the
beginning was
how many games of triple a you honestly
believe come out from first party
there'd be years between the sequels
right or wrong no i'm not no well it
will so with them with this amount of
this amount of development teams
you're going to have a lot of aaa titles
so game pass is definitely going to pay
off but you know
and it's good that they overturned it i
have one major problem with my
playstation 5.
i paid for the system already
right
i don't mind if it's game 70 listen we
spoil we've been on 65
dollar games for years so technically
it was a five dollar up it was a five
dollar upgrade not really a ten
but why
are you charging me
for features that's built into my
controller for the game
why did i pay 10 hours for that
hey that's that playstation tags
i like it nobody talks about that i
don't even use haptic feedback because i
don't like it but why do i have to pay
for it i already bought the system
that's kind of cool
yeah for sure
you're charging me for something that i
already paid for for a feature in a game
nah i got it turned off anyway and i i
could i can understand charging them
that ten dollars if you get the ps5
version after the ps5 came out but the
part that blew my mind is they're
charging people to get that that had the
playstation 4 version if you bought
spider-man go sushima and you wanted
that ps5 version you already gave them
the money for that game you shouldn't
have to
re-commit to get the next version of
that game when the aversion exists if it
doesn't exist that's different if you
can't physically go out there and get
that you can't force sony to get that
but if somebody has that on there and
they're charging that to the new if you
went out there it's like i said if you
went out there limited you picked up
that 70 dollar version then at that
point it is what it
i picked up is 200 version but you get
what i'm saying the statue and all that
stuff and they still want to charge me
for haptic feedback
nah nah my version should have been
included
with that because that's crazy
nah can't do that bro come on man
respect my wallet
that's crazy man
i can't co-sign that i don't mind the 70
dollar games man but listen man i can't
co-sign that oh you know what it is a
ten dollar jump because 75 dollars with
taxes 76 is some change yeah that is a
ten dollar jump
that is true let me correct that
that's crazy so yeah it's true it is
what it is when it comes to that also
you want to comment anything before you
move on
um
one way you shouldn't have bought that
uh that horizon join because i almost
fell into that trap too though um i
wanted that statue as well i'm glad i
didn't buy it um
as far as commenting on no i bet it is i
better know i better
um as far as everything else um i just
wanted to take the time to thank
everybody in the chat i see a couple
couple people in in the chat right now
so xbox university there pixel bit jeep
and dropping a lot of knowledge in that
chat just wanna say we appreciate you
all
trying to yeah yeah now i'm taking a
look at it and um thank you all for
hitting that like button man it's always
fun to do this and
um you know as we move on
you know hopefully we can make some more
memories attic what is the next topic
myself my conference go ahead and get
these super chats real quick and then
we're going to move on to the next
mid-gen refreshes uh might have been
right uh so we got the airline the
darkness five dollar super chat replaced
was delayed due to devs being located in
burlesque and ukraine 2023 will be an
epic year i will agree stuff that's been
naturally delayed of 2023 it's making an
already stacked year pretty much stacked
i just i asked the developers uh there's
more months than just february march
like can we can we can we
like sprinkle them throughout the year
we had so much what it is it's about
it's about quarters man
yeah i get that then we got a two dollar
super chat
pixel bit g the ps upgrade issue has
been reversed three hours ago
shout out to sony for reversing because
sometimes they don't listen to people
shout out don't never listen
got a two dollar supercharger
cloud gaming
who's yellow
big cloud
it was me
uh then we got a
i think that's all for right now yeah
that's all all right so let's
let's go and move on to
it looks like tcl you guys know how king
feels about that's their his favorite
brand he's got them everywhere in his
house uh looks like they might have
accidentally leaked
the next gen
mid refresh
consoles i don't know what they'll call
the series maybe series x version two i
think that's probably where they'll go
with that i don't know uh and the ps5
pro
uh
we're gonna go and start hustle this one
i'm kind of curious how you feel about
do you feel like we need mid gen
refreshes of these current consoles held
within two years it looks like
do we need it do we need it no do we
need it this no do we need it yes do we
need it as soon no um so i did a live
stream on that i don't think we even see
these or even start to sniff these until
like 2025.
when i say it like that 2025 is what i
wanted to say i don't think that's like
why i say it like that anyway um i don't
think we see it until then um as far as
you know i'm i'm for it for this very
good reason
we can't really get no ps5 over to no
xbox series x's out in the stores like
that because the boxing scalpers so if
they have the opportunity to make more
and even stronger hallway by all means
you go ahead and do that by all means
you go ahead and do that so that way
everybody can at least try to get one or
whatever the case may be
now we what i would like to see is uh
whatever the next uncharted game is for
me personally or last of us remake
whatever i want to see that push the ps5
to his limits but that won't happen
anyway because
the last of us is actually rumored to
come out this year and i put roman and
quotation marks
we probably won't see nothing like that
until we see the next uncharted we
probably won't see that until the last
of us three we probably won't see that
until spider-man um two spider-man 2
yeah yeah right yeah
we probably won't see this ps5 get
pushed and even with spider-man because
spider-man will come out next year god
of war comes out this year we won't see
the old gps
sound weird saying that we won't see the
ps5
we want to see the vanilla ps5 get
pushed to his limits for quite some time
anyway so like here's the thing do you
need it no
however you need it for the simple fact
that the the ps5s in particular are hard
to get even um even xboxes the series s
is like super easy i can leave right now
go to the store and come back with one
that's easier um
series x is not so much i think you can
kind of still be if you want one bad
enough you gotta you know be on your
phone all day long yeah you got yeah pun
intended of course
you gotta you gotta really be on it for
that but um thanks no do do we need it
do we need it right now no would i like
would i love to see it yeah because
hey look i like hallway dog i ain't
going to hold you plus i want to see
like how much what more can you add at
that point because you're talking about
4k 120 right at one point i saw people
tweeting out 8k yo bruh i want to just
be something you know i want to say
something perfectly clear for everybody
here you know as far as playstation and
xbox they ain't really mastered 4k yet
in my humble opinion i saw my 4k 120.
they really they ain't hitting that
but they're not even at 4k 120 every
multiplayer game yeah
enjoys 1080p 120 if you're lucky and
i don't know i just i always look at it
like the the the
upgrading of consoles like i think it's
cool i think this console generation is
going to last 10 years so that way and
just to extend the life on it just so
people can get familiar with the hallway
what's x86 so i think they're already
familiar with the architecture and
everything so i think everything is
going to be cool i saw um shout out to
shiv mom in the chat yeah i saw amd's a
new card on there too i'm team green
over here though baby so you know that
ain't really bothering me too much you
know we have video all day over here but
um i think it's i think it's cool like i
said is it needed not right now but it
will be needed in the future and i think
this generation's gonna go until 2030 in
my humble opinion um 20 30.
yeah yeah i give it 10 years i give it
10 years considering the actual economic
situation that we're here right now
would anybody else like to go
this is where do you feel uh 108 do you
feel like listen this is needed
hell no
this is not needed
they ain't even touched the power of
these two systems and let's just keep it
funky
the person that owns a ps5 we're not
gonna even talk about the series x the
person that owns the psr5 has a better
game
console
than
the pc dude the average pc dude can't
even do what the ps5 does
so what would we be tr what would be
what technical specs would be would we
be chasing
what are we trying what would you want
ray tracing in everything that's the
only other thing he could possibly do or
higher resolution i have an ak tv and
trust me i don't care about gaming in 8k
i want solid performance in 4k i want
you to give me these effects but what
numbers honestly would they be chasing
this has faster ram than
pcs
it has architecture built faster than
pcs pcs don't even have what is that
thing called quick
resume come on what features of hustle
what are we doing here
hey people want a pro as a lot of people
ain't got an x they ain't got a
playstation 5.
some people ain't got essence listen
what numbers are we chasing for
everybody to say we need to refresh
you didn't harley refresh with the
playstation 4 pro or the xbox one x only
the elite dudes did that and
who is this for i did want to say this
to in reference to a lot of pc gamers
you know a lot i got
mama right strong enough to go 4k i
often game at 1440p and um we're not
gonna go according to that steam survey
the way to say hey you know let me give
you like a stat that says post your rig
or something a lot of them a lot of them
posted a lot of them gaming at 1080p
still so no no no no doubt no doubt yeah
they they think they're going to tell
them
they could tell what resolution you're
playing that do do do the schemes
yeah that's how they report it that's
what i'm saying like hustle listen i got
a monster pc
i was getting my pc before i upgraded i
was playing the witcher
in 4k in 2015
in 2015
so i'm saying
if people are asking for a pro right
which
i don't see why
what
feature do you think or ability we
really chase in here at this point
these consoles are ahead they're not
behind
xbox one was definitely behind
ps4 did 1080p gaming but not with it all
the bells and whistles shines you know
what i'm saying there was limitations so
i could see in that generation okay we
see what the xbox one x did it was a
huge graphical difference compared to
the xbox one console right
the the playstation the playstation 4
pro outperformed the regular vanilla
playstation
what would we be getting in a pro in any
one of these editions that would matter
there's nothing not to say
that oh they're lacking this they're
lacking that they ain't lacking anything
technically we got 16 gigs of ram what
is dudes on pc got 16 gigs of ram that's
what i got i still got 16 gigs ddr4 and
i ain't bout to upgrade right
ain't no need so when you hear these
people who claim to be because i'm in
the leaders i want the best of
everything
i'm not buying it you didn't even take
advantage of what we got i don't want to
hear that series x plus or whatever they
would call it i'm not buying that come
on man i just gave you a thousand
dollars with two systems with no games
oh man
well well i'll say this in terms of you
know i like hallway too baby
yeah i mean it's it's cool like i just
want more people to you know have it
available to him but you know we was
talking about you know you know how
games visually look but we can't talk
about performance because somebody in
the chat had mentioned that you know a
lot of people if you don't have like a
c1 right or if you don't have a high
refresh rate like oled or even tv at
this point
a lot of people maybe people game on
monitors but do people do a lot of
people have the 4k
with monitor resistances issues
let me let me actually 2.1 on it because
i don't got that i got to join with how
much that tv with no other tv don't how
much is that monitor with no tv features
that's true that's that's oled high-end
money right oh the new oh the new 32 win
stream that's right like three grand i
spent two grand on my g c
who who who chasing what
and never again though i told dudes in
the in the podcast in 2019 right i said
when these consoles drop no excuse me
early 2020 i said when these consoles
drop
you keep talking about
um um on
tvs you know i said once these consoles
drop and they do what they say they're
gonna do
now you're gonna see what a high-end
dude is paying to play at the
resolutions because nobody wants to
spend three thousand dollars for 27 or
32 wins tv excuse me monitor
monitor yeah monitor it don't adjust it
all the time to take advantage of these
consoles so listen listen like i said i
don't know what we think we will be
chasing but these i'm not i'm not buying
it i'm sorry
i'm sorry you would have to no i don't
know
no i'm not doing it
i'm not doing it look
i
i personally feel like because i play a
lot of my games on monitors i don't play
them on tvs
um
i do feel like look was there some
performance differences between the xbox
one and the xbox one x yes was there
performance differences between the ps4
and the ps4 pro
yes
but i feel like
that whole model doesn't make sense you
buy a new system
because you
like
subconsciously want to see drastic
differences
and i feel like there was some games
that had a good difference but i don't
feel like there was enough games
all of them to justify that purchase
i feel like you you bought it because
you didn't want
the performance to be lacking when
you're playing like multiplayer games
when you're playing
you know uh fps uh models are different
but i don't feel like
there was enough drastic difference
to justify that kind of price point the
upgrading in general
the confusion when you get these not to
mention some games had them some games
didn't
i don't feel like it works because
you're never going to have a scenario
where they're going to have a game
that's exclusive to that platform
you're never going to have a developer
taking full advantage of any type of
hardware that's above the xbox series
systems and above the ps5
i feel like we need
to
be vocal about this because
i think playstation and xbox are doing
it because they know people are going to
buy it
and until like you always have like this
middle centro
they won't developers won't
go too much because they know this side
can't walk can't run it and they won't
go
too high
because they know that
it's pointless because the install base
is too low
so they're always going to have like a
middle ground where it's like
a performance mode a quality mode but
the problem is
we already get that now
performance mode quality mode so
i feel like all you're doing is just
confusing the market even more
now
at that point
were you midway through the generation
just
instead of having a 10-year generation
just start the next generation two years
after you're supposed after that so you
have like six to eight year generations
instead of a ten-year generation i would
prefer you know what they say 2024 2025
is uh this mid-generation they assume is
going to come out just have the next
generation start 2026 2027
right like instead of waiting until like
20 20 30
because
all that does is extend the generation
for lackluster performance that you
would expect that next-gen hardware to
do
because it's not doing anything all it's
really doing
is letting these companies
promote these slogans that don't really
make sense 4k it's not 4k though is it
most of these games back then was like
an upscale version of that besides like
you know red dead redemption and for the
most part you're letting these people
chase these these phrases that make no
sense 120 frames but it's only like
eight games
like it's just like look
let's
max out these systems first let's
get
let's first off if you're making these
the uh the playstation 5 pro and the
xbox series whatever they're going to
name that
you're doing that in the past couple
years
because it takes researchers development
to do that so you have subconsciously
not given these developers enough time
to even utilize these because by the
time you start to see those first set of
games coming out for the xbox series x
and the xbox ps5
they're already being given another dev
kit okay we know you just did this
here's the new dev kits for the new
systems here's the new dev kit for the
ps5
okay but we literally just made one game
off of this don't matter make it off of
that
and then you're gonna have scenarios
where people
okay what's the point in having this
game
this new updated hardware when we can't
take advantage of it or we'll take
advantage of the next hardware systems
then why didn't you just wait for them
it's just like i just think it's
i just think that
we're at a slippery slope
last gen made a little bit of sense
because they already came out kind of
underpowered the ps4 and xbox one
they were under
where they should have been
but i don't feel like that's the case
this selection uh so what are you saying
hustle what what what do you say on this
um well i'm gonna respond to a fear um
fear of the flesh in the chat he said
bro
he thinks he's visually impaired because
he can't tell the difference between 60
frames and 120 frames i know you joking
around but yeah now you can definitely
tell that difference and if you play
something at 120 frames like i was doing
with gears 4 at the time and going back
to 60 frames
you will feel sluggish i know you're
joking around but i was going to respond
to you that in the chat um now he has a
point though
it's like sometimes
sometimes it's you can't
see it but you can feel it you can feel
it yeah you can feel it like i've i've
played
gears also and halo i played halo in 60
frames because i was streaming so i
plugged it up to my
to my capture card of course
and
i said damn i don't want to play 60 no
i don't want to play 60 no more it's the
thing not for nothing i play games two
anniversary collection at 400 frames a
sec like no no that 400 oh it wasn't
that hard it was at like
230 but it was at like 720p i think i
was just messing around one night just
messing around
yeah no it's super smooth it's super
smooth you can see that but um
attic as far as what i think about all
this man i mean like i said i think
concerts will extend into the 2030 range
i honestly don't even think they
incomplete well xbox and playstation and
nintendo for that matter are incompetent
with nintendo they doing their own thing
but
the the other big two are in competition
with one another and they're competing
with a pc they're really competing with
pc if we're being the reason why you see
the high frame rates in the first place
is because everybody was going to pc
like myself
i'm a proud pc gamer since 2017. i do
believe summer sometime around october i
think when i got my tenacity i agree
with you on that but at the same time if
you're trying to compete with pc
you're literally
you're in an unwinnable race you're
never going to catch up to people and
the moment you start to see their back
because you release the xbox series x
the ps5 oh we about to grab they shirt
they really stay next to things and it's
like they they done they done did the
100 mile sprint in 15 seconds oh they
gone
well damn we were so close like
listen the the the
the elitist like i have a high-end pc
hustler has a high-end pc you got
someone needing all right no
don't
t.i
i don't know if that's anything so
it's like
when you when you run a check on your pc
to see your performance
i was in the top two percent on the
planet that's not a lot that's not a lot
of people though
that's a little bit of people so who
were they chasing on pc too
hey you got me man but that's what we
got to do
it's just like
and you know what the crazy part is 108
nintendo be making games
that are
socially acceptable they review
extremely well they sell extremely well
and you can run it on a potato
yeah that's a fact so it's just like
nintendo literally comes out they say oh
that's cute you guys invested all this
research and development all this time
into these into this hardware that you
release it for maybe two to three years
oh we just released this the same day in
pokemon for the 18th time and we sold
more than all your exclusives combined
you played yourself sodium like yourself
like but don't forget nintendo used to
play that
power game too but they realized they
couldn't win they right so they stopped
because they stopped
the panasonic edition i have from japan
that thing was
come on man i think that's the issue
though i didn't get that sir
i live it i live in new york brother
hey man we had a huge import scene
me i see me david and cognisoft we all
shopped at the same stores hey real
quick
oh people people keep asking about my
shirt it's this shirt i don't know why
i do want to say this about about that
pants because i'm a retro cat for
referral that panasonic gamecube for
those who don't know is extremely rare
and i think they only made it in japan
only in japan you had to get an input
you you had to get it you had to get it
down that's that's lit let's see
see if i get that joint i'm gonna mod
that joint it's in a box somewhere in my
basement though i still have it now that
you're gonna be with some bread you know
that but yeah no it's that that's that's
that's the big thing um
i had a point that i was gonna make oh
no about pc gaming um also with the tcl
thing that happened today um they also
released a uh a new amd card and as you
all know amd has been working with xbox
and playstation so yeah console will
never win that war but they'll try their
best for the enthusiast so it is what it
is
yeah it's like i said man at the end of
the day
i i feel like
they should be focusing a lot of their
focus on the games like both of them
yeah like
man
sony makes very very successful
games but they still have a [ __ ] first
party uh shooter market
like they it's non-existent
and people always
the first person first person what sleep
first person who what
hey they got they got bunch over there
now we can't do that
man
we can do it because they got 20 years
in right all right yeah 20 something
years yeah we could do i mean do they
though
do they though because those games are
going to come out and they're going to
be
uh multi-player uh for the most part
so it's just like
yeah you know maybe they bought them
because they want to have a little bit
more of advantage when it comes to that
kind of game because i do think sony
they see
the multiplayer market and they see the
money they can make off of it like i'm
willing to bet you see these probably
made more money than something like god
of war because of uh of course it did
because of micro transactions
uh what night is free who's making more
money than them
yes i got over 460 dollars worth of
characters i counted it the overdue i
said this is crazy jesus
yeah i buy all the i'm a movie dude so
you put in
the avengers gotcha yeah batman and i
just bought robocop the other day some
of the people i missed i got that they
put thanos back in the stock yo listen
over 460
and what people don't realize that you
know god of war made a lot of money it
did but
when you have a a game that comes out
that you can realistically settle one
person one time with no micro
transactions and i'm not i'm not
co-signing micro transactions it's dog
[ __ ] but at the end of the day we in
this industry that's how it is now
there's nothing we could do about that
right but when you have something like i
do think that see these
microtransactions aren't intrusive it's
just like look if you want to look fly
while you're selling then you're going
to have to pay that fly money uh but
god of war they have to like people
think that they just make that whole 60
70 they don't they split of retailers
they sell it to gamestop
they split it to people uh they split a
percentage of that two to their what
whatever you know uh shipping
manufacturers they use they make the
most money off something like you know
if they sell it digitally uh they make
that full most of it for the most part
but
we can't act like god of war with that
20 20 plus million that we can't act
like they made all that either uh for
the most part some of that was bundled
some of that was on sale for five to ten
bucks uh you know they don't make all of
that strictly profit uh sea of thieves
they do an event they probably make
mad money every time they do anything
minecraft minecraft has made more money
than probably all of playstation so
it is what it is uh we got a five dollar
super chat from uh g uh uh four games
with quarters i love these guys man uh
tcl baby buy your playstation five gen
refresh with your 1080p tcl tcl equals
lct
lemon cosines this uh what is that about
kind of curious what that's about i
ain't co-signing nothing he's clowning
but but the super chats cosine so you
cosign listen listen listen that's
clowns is clowning you know i ain't i
ain't putting no teeth my daughter don't
even have a t a tco
we ain't doing that in here that's well
wait well i i do have a question before
you read that next super chat uh
hey um i saw i saw him in the chat
earlier he said what up hustle what up
addict what up lemon uh was backstory on
that or was it
that's my nickname okay all right cool i
didn't know only addict calls me 108.
like okay okay
here's the thing though if you're going
to come to the zoo meeting it literally
asks you what you want to be called and
you put one away
i'm not going to disrespect here's the
thing like the reason i the reason that
i didn't really call you limit too much
is because you put that in there and i
don't i don't know if you want people
calling you that so that's why i called
you one day let me let me explain let me
explain my name real quick when i was
little when i was little my mom's passed
right my family been calling me lemon on
my life my daughter thought that was my
real name
on an open school night yeah she thought
that was my real name but my mom's when
she had me she the doctor you know how
to put you about they spank you make you
cry you know get get the juices flowing
so she said i kept balling up and my
mom's puerto rican she's like he's
balling up like a little limonga so
i went from little lemon to six five big
women i mean hey
but that's that's that's where it comes
so i really just keep my name even on my
job that's what they call it that's all
it is what's funny is my
i have like i've had like several names
growing up
there's this chick that uh
uh me and my cousin storm knew and like
uh when we went to
uh like this kind of like community
center that you would play basketball
she called me applejacks i don't know
why people for the longest time
would take my initials which was aj and
they would run like they would run with
it call me all kinds of stuff with a and
j apple jacks you know we don't know why
she called you that no no it's aj apple
jacks like they they would just find
random stuff and that that stuck for a
little bit uh then i went by uh room to
kill that was my um that was my gamer
tag for a long time until my until
cognito convinced me to change it to
lord attic with these weird-ass numbers
because of this new system that
microsoft i know
you know what's crazy i tried to take
gaming attic didn't work someone someone
had it with like a hundred gamer score
it's one of those people i guarantee you
that i wanted to play car that wanted to
play call of duty or halo back in the
2000s the early 2000s that did it just
for that free month of xbox live and now
i can't be the people i want to be and
you got to have these weird-ass name
numbers beside my name because it's some
dude that wanted to get a whole year oh
my god man just talking you know you
know what's funny you know let me move
let me move my mic a little bit you know
you know what's funny
uh-oh if you if if someone in the chat
someone in the chat that did that
that did that to me that that i have
these numbers in my name because of you
if you are in that chat i'ma say this
i hate you
because i'll be sitting there no no no
no
let me finish i'll be sitting there and
i'll be i i'll be in my i'll be i'll be
doing good man i'll be like oh
great day then i see the damn numbers
and i'm looking at those numbers and i'm
like really really why those numbers
there i can understand if those numbers
there and like the tech wise the server
y microsoft why am i on a party with
lord attic 5278 or whatever the hell
those numbers are
why why can't people see that microsoft
why can't you get rid of that why do
people have to see it when i'm in a
discord call with people they don't see
those numbers what's up with that what's
up with that microsoft they don't see
those numbers
how you gonna steal someone's idea by
putting numbers and giving you people
more opportunities to make gamer tags
which i love it you know for the longest
time if you wanted to make a gamer tag
you couldn't really do none
but how you gonna take half day ideal
microsoft
how you gonna take half the idea
when i joined a discord voice call
they don't see those numbers you know
what they see they see gaming addicts
they don't see gaming
they see gaming at it they don't see
none of that so why can't i join a party
on xbox live microsoft and it says lord
addict and that's all
right done
yo i do that i do have a question oh man
i see they spamming the spam dilemmas in
the chat um i got a question about that
no yeah let me just go good with
everything drinks seafood everything
stephen good were you sick
oh indeed indeed um now like i learned
it from luca like a long time ago to be
like hey you got to make sure your name
is the same everywhere see i see mike
lowery see when i see mike lowry in the
chat i know who he is on twitter right i
saw ella in here so i'm gonna show my
hunger ella in here um
a wildly ella rather i know who that is
everywhere i go that's just the thing i
mean you know hey wait i was going to
ask you ain't no way i guess you
wouldn't change your name but do you
think there's any way if you did change
your name could you add like spacebars
or like underscore because i had to do
that on my youtube name
i put hustler motivate in there and i
think somebody took it but i think i put
like a spaceball or something crazy like
that so you can see my whole name and
all that um is there any way that you
can do that type of thing without losing
your game it's going all that or like
what are you talking about
i don't know like you know okay so you
can on youtube for instance like when
you change your name when you when you
set everything up you don't particularly
have to go by your name i go about
hustling and motivating the thing
because
of what i did in the google
settings or whatever i did it with i put
hustler motivated on the first line and
then i put a spaceball on the second
lock
yeah i saw that too
i saw that too um you're clowns i'ma
roast you tomorrow
clowns he came in there and he said i'm
gonna let you live today but tomorrow
i'm gonna let you live the day but
tomorrow tomorrow
you know you know clowns that's even
worse for you know why i say that's
worse for you clowns because this man
said
i ain't gonna go off the top of my head
i'm gonna go in the i'm gonna go in the
workshop i i'm a premature you know
people you get you know when you do that
and you commit homicide that's first
degree murder he's saying he's gonna
first degree yo ass he gonna go home and
he's gonna think about what he's gonna
say to you
so i would be scared clown i would you
know i yo you know what i would do if i
was you clown
i would go ahead and call in tomorrow
you don't need to be there
you know let him do that stuff you don't
need to be there
you know
that's the ultimate thing you can do
clown is you can tell him
you're gonna go there and you're gonna
talk and you're gonna write down this
script but i think we'll be there here
okay so uh we got a two dollar super
chat for clowns let me go good with
pineapple two what is that about
i've never tried that
you see my man clown shout out to 4gq tv
in the building my man clowns is italian
right
him cerebral pal several other guys we
podcast with that all we all have
conversations with so i told them
when me and my daughter or the dominoes
we get half pineapples they say
pineapples don't go on pizza yes it does
yes it does
yes
because they hardcore italian men we
don't eat that i said well when you
bring your food to america we switch it
up
so
french french don't make french fries
but we call them french fries
so it is what it is we take it we put
our spit on it listen it is what it is
my neighborhood we go to our pizza shops
all of them got brown mustard if you
don't have you have a pizza shop in
brownsville in brooklyn and you don't
have brown mustard nobody's gonna come
in your pizza shop because that's what
we put on our pizzas brown mustard all
right oh god okay
not yellow mustard got to be the spicy
mustard just put it up i do i do want to
say this um hey can you make a poll can
you make a poll in the chat um can we
see if uh
pizza goes on pizza on that can we make
that poll in the chat you know
i'll do it so i do it just because you
asked but
you know damn well this is about to
start some some beef in the chat man
does pineapples belong on pizza
listen if you've never had it
i feel like you're doing yourself a uh
you know
so you definitely are man
but the pineapple is good as hell the
pineapple's got a hit right though you
can't just we have no dryers pineapples
we can join like it gotta it gotta be
right it gotta be right it definitely
gotta be oh damn clown's gonna get
pissed off
i'm just saying man and
you know and i know that you well attic
i know you're from a different part of
part of the world um
you know what um lemon something call
you let me look i know you up there in
new york but if y'all have y'all ever
had mumbo sauce before i know but cause
mom's like the hell is mumbo sauce what
is that
okay if i'm ever around y'all and i got
a feeling i will be i'll make sure i
bring some mumbo sauce it's kind of like
sweet and sour sauce but way better it's
like it's a dc made thing it's kind of
like we yo we made our own genre and
music and go go we made our own sweet
and sour sauce we went to dc
yeah well i'm in maryland yes but yeah
yeah yeah yeah i know as soon as you
said go go i already knew what it is
yeah that's how it how university
parties let's go
but if you really you know was about it
you know you went to the black hole and
if you really if you oh you had to
nevermind that that's the conversation
that the clock okay it's coming
all right let's let's move on uh we got
that that poll in the chat on uh on
hustle's request
thank you speaker
nonsense so here here okay here so
there was some rumors going around uh
that you know not necessarily the rumors
i i think it's pretty much confirmed at
this point that microsoft
in 2014 had the opportunity to
get themselves some type of marvel ip
from actual marvel themselves i i read
into the actual uh
the the articles that was following
around it looks like it came from
someone that used to be at marvel where
is currently at marvel and what happened
is he got tired of the current
relationship that they had with
activision so they were looking for a
new home for their products and looks
like they did go to the console
manufacturers and i would assume
that's how you got marvel versus
alliance three on the switch
because that seemed about the same time
that uh you know that would have
happened so i would assume that's how
uh the nintendo got that uh relationship
going um you know clearly sony
requested spider-man and they made it
insomniac but then
when they went to xbox they said yo
we good hand we good fab take your palm
go home it looks like so it looks like
microsoft uh you know they said that you
know for his recollection you know which
i think it's interesting that he worded
it that way that he didn't
that he thinks that's what they said
that they said they were working on
their own ips and then keep in mind this
is back before civil war happened uh
before spider-man was put in the mcu uh
also keep in mind that microsoft uh you
know spider-man was doing good in like
the comic book world and the movie war
to a point but i won't say it was doing
that great game wise uh you know i would
say that activision probably made one
good spider-man game the rest average
and you know what we're going to talk
about is do you think that microsoft
made the right choice back then because
clearly we could talk in hindsight all
we want and say they made the wrong
choice but you got to put yourself in a
microsoft 2014 scenario this is right
around the corner that they had the bad
launch of the xbox one uh this is around
the time i would say that microsoft was
shopping around to people theoretically
buying xbox uh so you know we're going
to start with uh 108 like what did what
first off what was your mindset when you
first saw this that you know we talk a
lot about microsoft you know needing
their own comic book hero and it looks
like
at one point in time they could have had
it and they didn't and then you know the
second part of that question is uh do
you think uh back then it was the right
choice let me get this super chat real
quick because uh you i don't know what
you guys have started in this chat uh
mambo sauce is a dmv area staple
dc
maryland virginia all right so i don't
know what mama sauce is i i guess i
guess you got some dude in his basement
making it in that area because i've
never heard of that no
no it's not a kind of basement no if
you know what thank you for your super
chat it's about the most gangster super
chat that i'm saying today so i really
appreciate that super chat yes mama
sauce is really good let's let's go
ahead and get back one topic 108 would
you like to take it away sir
listen
i think they made a smart decision
and i'm gonna tell you why
because we ended up
in the hands of insomniac making that
great game i'm not mad that microsoft
didn't
didn't bite because who was they going
to get to make it back then
studios to to make you know
the game is great let me interrupt you
real quick i respect what you just said
because
that said
yo microsoft definitely needed a comic
book hero
but because they did that we got
something as amazing as spider-man you
know theoretically you could say that
that was gonna happen regardless we
don't know if they offered microsoft at
first but what i like about that is it
said microsoft denied it now
maybe they'll get it
that microsoft delayed it then but maybe
they'll get it now but because they
denied it then
there is a domino effect an alternative
world a marvel universe world where they
accept that
it's average as hell because they didn't
realistically have a studio to make that
game or they would like uh you know
outsource it and
it made comic book games worse
uh because of something like insomniac
what i would say batman kind of started
that trend were to show how you can make
good comic book heroes but i would say
spider-man elevated that more mainstream
and because of that you're having stuff
like uh you know wolverine being made i
would it's arguably saying guardians of
the galaxy may never have been made
without that comic book interest that
sony and rocksteady and warner brothers
started uh continue uh 108.
so nah that was pretty much it what was
the second part of your question again
it was just saying like you know
yeah
what was your mindset when you heard
that like when you first heard that they
could have gone listen well you know
there's many things they pass upon as
any major corporation does that we don't
know about you know like you know but
listen man
it's a business everything that come
across they played they don't eat
they got you know and sometimes like i
said with this situation insomniac
landed spider-man with sony and look at
look at what we got so with that we
don't know what we would have had you
can't say well they could have made in
this amazing game and i'm realistic they
didn't have the dev teams look what
happened with crackdown
that got the sad part how many times the
sad part is crackdown could have been a
good game you know that's a different
conversation yes and it was i don't
think it was bad i just think it could
have been way better and i'm a crackdown
series dude and i was the only one
playing the multiplayer by myself it was
it was not good so what do you think
hustle
what do you think yeah
um
i i agree with 108 dragons i'll get into
that but i want to play devil's advocate
on that too all right so microsoft not
getting that oh xbox not getting a
spider-man title cool because they
really the only dev team in my opinion
who they could have given that to anyway
it would have been the coalition in the
coalition as we know had to ask us when
they backed the last generation with
gears full gives five gears tactics
right they had them
on the back say y'all come on we got
y'all so they backpacked through the
whole way through
um
it's kind of like like a hip-hop
reference right so typically like lupe
fiasco he has a song called beautiful
girls
i forget who that song went to first but
that song went to somebody else first
and
then like with the label to do the label
that we like the label did what kind of
what like marvel was doing right it's
like hey we about to give you this thing
or go make a hit you don't get the bruno
mars uh lupin fiasco song beautiful
girls all over the world
you don't get all that oh i said bruno
mars it's a b.o.b
and
b.o.b and bruno mars i do believe anyway
y'all know who made that record you
don't get that record
for my race to five nine and genuine i'm
just naming two different artists right
you don't get that song like you don't
get like uh
nelly furtado's loose album with the
production of timberland from a marie
i'm and i'm putting those examples out
there because it's two different people
two different teams
yeah i mean like things are different
one is a big prime example hustle what's
about snoop turning down that in the
club beat and gave it and they gave it
to 50.
well d12 i think d12 i think you got
that with d12 no and it was d202 they
passed it along the lines yep they
passed that joined up look what happened
history but again so that that's a very
real thing but i do want to play i do
want to play a devil's advocate man i i
want this degree for the sake of
disagreeing i'm allowed i'm allowed
if microsoft look listen i'm only going
to say it's an l on microsoft
because you know spider-man if it if it
is spider-man right
they activation had a really good run
with them some good something bad but
like i think toward the end it was like
really good you know shout out to mr
magic players because he got a video up
on that too but if if you're me
and like microsoft at that time they
don't really have no regardless of like
because you could tell what the
landscape was with the comic book movies
and all that back in 2014. so you can
kind of tell where things were going
nobody thought that they would have
ballooned the marvel universe with
balloon as high however
if you kind of could tell a little bit
to be like you know let's try it
i mean you get him to try it like
granted maybe insomniac doesn't make it
maybe but but again right you you put
you know three four three with a five i
mean three for three um the coalition
would have filed a class action lawsuit
against him putting them boys and boys
and girls to work over there so hard but
i would have had the coalition make that
i would have definitely had and then you
know how i said is obviously 20 20. yeah
forget all that
or like for real just turned in turn 10
aren't they making is it turn no it's
playground isn't it playground who's
making a fable yeah they make a fable
right
yes you could've gave that to them all
that but i mean i don't know they didn't
they didn't have they didn't have them
then
but then they always have like a tight
relationship yeah yeah yeah
to be fair
sony didn't have uh
installment oh yeah no doubt no doubt no
doubt i'm just looking at the ending
program but that's 100 percent yeah you
know
and when you think about it that's
around the time where sunset overdrive
launched
so microsoft would have you know maybe
theoretically had a better relationship
with insomniac at that time because
that's the time where they just let them
they funded a game didn't own the ip
didn't ask for it uh you know one would
think that unless there was some kind of
bad blood from sunset overdrive that
they would have been more open to doing
it with microsoft than sony would have
it is what it is you know i don't really
have too much to say when it comes to
this thing we do have a second part of
the question uh but you know when it
comes to this particular one
i think there's multiple factors that
play in it i think one of the factors is
like let me say who gonna make it at
that time they didn't really have it now
you could say that they could
order out you know get to get a second
party studio to make it like insomniac
um i feel like it's different for sony
to do it because sony sure they were
making some set of overdrive for
microsoft but i don't think that
that
defeats making ratchet and clank in all
the games that
and sonic made for sony for all those
years
uh so i think that you know it is what
it is that not in hindsight they took
the l
but at that time like i said
spider-man still isn't in the mcu
technically uh you know he has been
introduced
they came off of
average at best spider-man games from
activision so i could see from a
logistics standpoint microsoft's looking
at it okay do we really need this and
then you gotta you know
elephant in the room microsoft didn't
know if they wanted to keep the xbox
brand at that time anyway
so why would you make investments to
that degree with a brand you are
uncertain of and you don't know what
you're gonna do with uh so i do think
that that
is acceptable maybe microsoft should
have been a little bit more faith in
their own
studios but i can understand why they
want that direction
but this that's your question let me ask
you a question real quick before you
move on
we got a game that sold 10 million
copies from xbox
and what halo 5
no no
killer instinct
and we couldn't even get a sequel with
that because they don't got enough
development because iron galaxy was off
doing something else
and that's all i've always said
you can't even make your own games
you're gonna take on another one and
that's why i've always been very firm
that they should buy nether realm they
should have a first party studio because
here's microsoft got burnt so many times
with the rice center roams
uh you know maybe not so much sunset
overdrive because i don't think they
were ever gonna fund that game a sequel
to that uh you know they got they got
they got burnt by a few studios uh they
they funded pretty much two generations
of
of deaths of dead rising games where
where did that get them in the in the
long run uh they funded quantum break
where did that get them in the long run
they funded rice center rome where did
that get them in the long run uh
recourse sure they own the ip to that
but they don't own the studio where did
that get them in the long run uh so i
feel like microsoft now i felt they have
the better approach
you know
we're never going to really rely on
second party people to make our games
ever again we're going to use global
publishing let them go out there and you
know there's little different things
that global publishing is doing one
they're
they're putting money into ecosystems of
developers and stuff that they don't own
uh they're they're pro they're giving
more of a diversity of of a portfolio on
the xbox and game pass
and there's
what people don't really realize about
that team as well is
they're scouting talent as well
yes uh when they're going out there
funding these games funding these ip's
that's what i id at xbox is doing too
they're seeing
in the in the future when we start
looking for other studios to purchase
okay this studio might be something we
need to look at in the future and i
think you know you're seeing that i
think that's the right move
but this next one
uh maddie play shout out to the defining
duke uh that's the uh the host of uh
defining duke that kog does
he said that he heard
that they also had the opportunity
to make courtuar
the remake that's going on over there at
sony as the exclusive that they have the
opportunity to make that an exclusive on
their platform
and they turn that down
and
if that's true and i believe maddie
but if that's true
straight l
straight up l
because there's no realm of possibility
where it makes me think that
you couldn't have found a developer for
that
because you goddamn near all the studios
that do that type of game
there is no amount of work that make me
think that that could not have worked
for them
that not to mention
that's a star wars title that's a very
big thing going on right now
because disney's making all that stuff
pop
but wait till friday they're remaking a
game
they're remaking a game that popped on
they stuff
and they said we good
go give that to someone else
and because they said no
it shows up and now it's making
playstation's lineup look better
where
that's an l i'm sorry that's the that's
one of the biggest l's i think i've seen
for them in a long time so what where do
you feel about that hustle
well that i didn't know um so when you
when you just hit me well for that
information just now i had no idea and i
know maddie wouldn't know because the
boys coach all crazy out there
um yeah that's that's something that is
it's kind of strange that they passed on
that
um
i don't know man i don't know i mean
who's who makes those decisions over
there
man i'm not talking about the i'm
talking about this this most this most
recent decision because star wars you
know for better for worse even though
i'm not a star wars cat i understand how
hot that franchise is right now i
understand that people you got people
watching the mandalorian boba fett et
cetera et cetera yeah i understand how
hot that franchise is so
if i had the opportunity and you know
culture like i do remember that being on
the ogx box i never played it but i do
remember people going yeah it started it
was on the og xbox yep and i remember
working at gamestop and people were
still the sequel was on it too
the knights of the republic too like yep
i think for the legacy purposes
you kind of snatched up like where
everything begins right or something you
whatever it's not even legacy too like
perception wise that looks bad
but you bring back phantom dust
who acts for that
i mean what what's that other game the
um
there's a few games they brought back
that we're scratching our head but
something like that they don't approve
like hey you know what's crazy
sony eventually i have a feeling in the
next five years we're going to see a
sunset overdrive 2 announcement
and
sony is the kind of person to approve
that kind of
that that kind of game and fun that kind
of game
just for perception wise oh you know
what you that was you got you had uh the
prequel on your stuff we gonna take the
sequel and sony the kind of person to
put all the money in all the marketing
and that just to say our [ __ ] was
popping yours wasn't
it is what it is man because at the end
of the day i feel like that would have
been a good art not sure do they need to
know
they got a vowel they got elder scrolls
six elders girl six is worth ten of them
but at the same time
that looks bad man you put that game on
the map and when the remake was being up
there you said no to now sure maybe the
studio is already making the game and
they were shopping around for
exclusivity thing and maybe microsoft
saw the game and said that ain't it we
ain't doing that that's that's not it
but we don't know we ain't seen no
gameplay on the game yet uh so i'm i'm
curious to exactly you know what that is
they i just i just find it very crazy
that something to that caliber something
that is beloved like knights of the old
republic star wars knights idaho
republic microsoft said that's not it
we're not doing that and it's just like
but you approve stuff like sunset
overdrive
sure i got no issue with the game and i
felt like it
it was a good game for the diversity of
the platform at that time but you
approved that but you're telling these
people no
like it's just like i just don't
get it they and right now
i feel like microsoft is so
total focused on we got to make sure our
stuff's good we got to make sure our
stuff does this we got to make sure our
stuff does that rips this rieps that and
they're like
how you let couture go
like sometimes
they got to do a better job at
seeing what our houses are doing
but having our eyes looking everywhere
else oh that looks good here come here
come here man someone get the train
ticket yeah get them over here like no
no no plane ticket okay it doesn't
matter get them over here it's like
they're just looking at what they're
doing and they're letting sony snatch
everything around them
i mean we don't get final fantasy 7
remake final fantasy 6 16 for spoken
there's so much that's going to the
competition and it's like microsoft's
not even looking at third-party stuff
sometimes if you don't want to pay the
exclusivity deal to make it exclusive to
yours you need to at least come in the
middle and pay that that's not going
over their exclusive money
yeah
but then i guess that would i guess that
would open uh uh up a uh a hole maybe
you don't want happening because
then
you're gonna have all these people it's
like if we withhold the game for place
microsoft they're going to pay us money
and then before you know it that's kind
of that's kind of blackmailing you know
we're not putting the game on your
platform it's not from an exclusivity
deal it's because we know you're going
to come and give us money to put it on
your platform and i honestly think
that's what's happening in some of these
japanese games i think uh they know that
game pass check nice and they waiting
for that game pass check and unless
microsoft gives them that game pass
check they're not coming like that so
you know that's pretty much it man you
know
one away man lemon appreciate you coming
on what what are you going to be doing
in the next couple weeks man tell tell
the people what you doing well first i
think we should give microsoft some
props and a round of applause for
something that nobody's really talking
about that happened this week
at activision for them getting a union
the first
major
video came
publisher to have a union
you know what's kind of crazy things are
working out and activision i'm kind of
curious that that happened because they
wanted that to happen or because they're
like the ftc stooping up on us we don't
want to look any kind of negative
whatsoever obviously i'm not taking away
from what microsoft happens
but i'm curious that that's a domino
effect because of
them taking the advantage of this deal
going on that microsoft really had no
choice but to do it even if they wanted
to i'm pretty sure that they even if
they didn't want to i'm pretty sure they
had to because of this deal going on and
because they got them at this right time
i'm wondering if that's a domino effect
that's going to make units pop up
everywhere
well listen
it's it's it no matter what it is it's
good for the workers at the end of the
day their work environment will be
changed it will be protected and nasa
matters because we all know it was a
disaster
so it's good to say that
but i got some um as always i got my
podcast from 6 p.m
saturdays eastern standard time on my
channel 108 dragons tv and i'm i should
be dropping a video friday this week i
got something i'm trying to wait for it
to come in the mail
to give y'all a review on it so we'll
see what happens with that but yeah man
you go hit check out my content check
out my packs interviews with the devs of
course with my iron little brothers out
there we had a blast
um yeah runaway dragons tv man on
everything follow me on uh i guess
twitter and uh instagram it's one of the
way dragon tv is everywhere baby that's
what it is thanks for having me i
appreciate it when we get these uh last
couple of super chats real quick hustle
um let me make sure we got a two dollars
we got to get hustle on too yeah indeed
spartan ghost 17 what's your thoughts on
the guna young thug on the rice case
it's hold on okay
i gotta i gotta block somebody in this
chat right quick hold on
um this is the
ricoh thing
it's a montgomery and young doug rico
case uh they finally hit thug with a
jersey number i hope that boy team um
hope his attorney is as strong as
linebackers but
he needed about a hundred of them right
now um
gunner in particular they're trying to
hit gunner with like federal conspiracy
rico so
they're saying that why the ysl thing is
a gang organization i'll just say this
gunner will probably beat
his
charge because he's just a rapper they
just they trying to make him seem like
he's one of the higher-ups because of
who he is not because necessarily of
what he's done but uh thug
hey hey look man
yeah you had a good run it might be over
for you homie that they they're trying
to get my man 20 year old good luck
nevermind
i'll just say i'll just say those are my
thoughts on that just uh
nah nevermind this this game in podcast
this game pop wait i don't want that i i
trap from shrimp kingdom microsoft value
uh values owning ips
reason for studio purchases i agree with
you on that but i do feel like we need a
point where microsoft needs to value
what a studio can do in the talent that
works there to make the the ips that
they currently have and not just what
the ips that come with the studio itself
uh but you know i appreciate it for
coming through uh you know hustle what
are you going to be doing here lately
next
well next well before i talk about what
i'm doing next let's talk about what i
did before i got here today i did a
34-ish minute little
thing on the whole ps5 xbox series x pro
thing thingies uh leaked by tcl so i
have fun doing that um this sunday more
than likely i should have it done i'm
gonna try to have it done by friday but
this sunday what i plan on doing is
having everything that we need to know
about teenage mutant ninja turtles
shredders revenge uh the game because
there are a lot of information coming
out about that that rollout has been
pretty heavy over the last couple days
so i plan on having that video by
hopefully sunday morning at 9 a.m
eastern standard time and saturday night
i don't know what the hell i call it but
on saturday night i streamed from like
seven to like 7 45 ish get you in and
get you all like a robbery a lot of
stuff that we cover here today we'll
probably be spoken about saturday and
i'm just coming up with a couple topics
but i cover like two or three topics
have a good time with the chat and if
y'all haven't done so go ahead and
follow me i'm on the road to 1 000
subscribers and i'm at 6 20 right now
matthew's 20. so
just you know slowly but surely break my
brick and doing my thing and um real
quick real quick i don't know if they're
in here but i want y'all to go support
level one tonight too i see uh 200 of
y'all in here man first of all hit that
like button for us but uh go support
level one and uh attic if you can give
me a second can i please link their
channel yeah yeah you don't mind
definitely yeah that's barry right
that's awesome fame entertainment
level one yeah i thought you took about
the website there was no no that's
that's uh gaming.net
oh no not no i'm talking about um level
one gaming
don't know that that's a
they have a website as well but um i
always like push the youtube stuff
because
if they love the podcast stuff here
y'all follow level one here yeah y'all
like the parts says stuff here that we
do
famous fam and baron in the big homies
over there yeah that's what i said oh no
no that was closergaming.net i didn't
know
yeah that's what's up oh bears i thought
you said
yeah that's why i thought he said
something okay now that's that's that's
what uh you know baron j67 and right i
mean the whole squad over there man
they've always been great to me sorry
anytime people's good peoples yep i'm
framing them the whole squad so anytime
i can be good for them i'll be good for
them um
yeah but y'all make sure y'all go check
them out in fact they come on um like
right before a smooth podcast so right
right before playing an xbox tonight
y'all make sure y'all check them out and
then you check out planet xboxing i mean
yeah we we all get it we all gonna push
for each other out here yeah and
definitely
that's it for me
now yeah you can find me on twitter
obviously to uh lord addict iop uh i'm
going to be doing more content on my
personal channel you know a little bit
of streams here now a couple times a
week because i'm just bored uh but
appreciative for coming through man uh
we we had a fantastic show had about 280
90ish people in here uh you know
definitely hit that like button if you
guys ain't hit it yet we're about to
close out of here i don't know who we're
gonna have on next week uh we are coming
up on the xbox show uh so that's gonna
be interesting i'm going to uh to look
into that um i we uh attic show won't be
reacting i saw some people saying that
uh iop reacts to stuff the attic show
don't but uh you know we might have
hustle in there if he got time but i
appreciate it for coming through
uh you know we'll see you next week man
until next week
we're out of here